shall Michael stand up, the great prince
which standeth for the children of thy
people. And there shall be a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation.
Even to that same time, and at that time
shall thy people be delivered, everyone
that shall be found written in the book.
Welcome to Q&A with Elder Randy Ske on
the word inspired. I am your host
Denanisha McCurchin and today we are
discussing preparation for the final
crisis. Let us have a word of prayer.
Heavenly Father, thank you for your
sweet Holy Spirit. Thank you for your
word which is the sword of the spirit.
Today as we delve into your word,
forgive us of our sins. Speak to us, oh
God, through your word and through your
manservant, Elder Randy SK. Father, may
someone be inspired, convicted,
impressed to live for you and prepare
for the events ahead. I thank you for
hearing and answering this prayer and
for putting a double outpouring of your
spirit on your man's servant today as
you use him to answer these questions.
In Jesus's name we pray. Amen. Amen.
>> Our special guest this afternoon is
family. In fact, I call him Papa.
>> He is a man of God that goes around the
world heralding the coming of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ. He has studied
for the ministry at Oakwood University
and the theological seminary at Andrews
University. He is the husband of one
wife and a father to many.
I speak of none other than Papa Randy
Ski and he is a nice man.
Please give Papa Randy Ski a warm
virtual welcome.
>> Thank you very much my lovely daughter.
How are you? I hope all is well by the
unfailing grace of God. Welcome to all
those connecting online wherever you
are. We thank God for the technology
that permits us to fellowship in this
way and discuss the eternal truths.
Again, let me state very clearly my
sense of privilege to be a part of this.
And may the God of truth, the Bible
tells us the father is truth, the son is
truth, the holy ghost is truth.
Consequently, the people of God should
be lovers of truth. And so I'm grateful
for this privilege to be a part of this
exercise. And may the truth find a
welcome in the hearts of all those who
listen today.
>> Amen. And amen. I also must say happy
belated birthday, Papa.
>> Oh yes. Yes.
>> We celebrated your birthday on the 25th
and we are so grateful that the Lord is
continuing to preserve and strengthen
you.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen. So let us get to our first
question. M
>> what is the final crisis and we can
consider revelation 13 15-17
I also recited Daniel 12:1
>> and the second part is when does it
occur I can read revelation 13 15-17 if
you like
>> papusk
all right before you read it let me just
uh ask God to give me wisdom father give
me wisdom simple language dear god
because the essentials of the gospel El
are simple. Speak clearly through me. I
pray in Jesus' name. Amen. The final
crisis refers not simply to one act.
Well, not to one act, but a series of
events that will create a crisis of
conscience. What do I mean by that?
Believers or the world will be brought
to the place where they have to choose
the authority of God or the authority of
man. Man is a generic term. How will
that crisis uh what will bring about the
crisis? We believe and you'll read a
passage shortly that there will be a
manmade law which already exists by the
way but not universally enforces
enforced a man-made law which will come
into conflict with God's law as found in
the ten commandments. And the particular
law of the ten commandments will be the
fourth remember the Sabbath day to keep
it holy. Sixth day shalt thou labor and
do all thy work, but the seventh day is
the Sabbath of the Lord thy God. That's
God's law. We know way back in 3:21 AD,
March the 7, Emperor Constantine passed
his law making Sunday generally a day of
rest and Saturday a day of worship. And
subsequently, church councils pass laws
supporting and extending that law of
Constantine. Now, if you read Revelation
13:15-17,
we'll get a sort of a hint or clue as to
how that crisis will come about. A
crisis of conscience. What do I choose?
Obedience to God or obedience to a
manmade law. Let's read those three
verses now.
And he had power to give life unto the
image of the beast
>> that the image of the beast should both
speak and cause that as many as would
not worship the image of the beast
should be killed.
>> All right. Right there we pause. In
prophecy, a beast refers to a power. For
instance, Daniel chapter 7, we have a
lion, we have a bear, we have a leopard,
and we have a nondiscript beast no one
had ever seen. They each represent a
power, a nation. The the lion represents
Babylon, the bear, middle Persia, the
leopard, Greece, and the nondescript
beast, Rome. Powers that literally
existed in that chronological order. And
so we have a prophetic statement,
Revelation 13:15. And he had power to
give life to the image of the beast. Who
is he? the beast that came up in verse
11 of Revelation 13 and does great
wonders uh in verse 13 all the way down
to verse 14. That power will enable this
beast to pass a law and that law will be
that if anyone does not worship the
beast that person or have his mark that
person should be killed. Uh keep reading
verse 16.
And he causth all, both small and great,
rich and poor, free and bond,
>> to receive a mark in their right hand or
in their foreheads.
>> And that
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> And that no man might buy or sell, save
he that had the mark or the name of the
beast or the number of his name.
>> All right. When the Bible say, "And he
causeth he is the beast out of power."
It's a government. It's a system. It's a
ruling system, a system of authority.
And he causes all both small and great,
rich and uh poor, free and bond to
receive a mark in the forehead. That all
does not literally mean every single
person. There will be a few who will not
accept that mark. We see that in uh
Revelation 12:9. And the great dragon
was cast out. That old serpent called
the devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world. Now he does not deceive the
whole world. He deceives most of the
world but a few are not deceived. In 1
John 5:19 and we know that we are of God
and the whole world lith wickedness. Not
the whole world overwhelmingly but there
are a few who do not lie in wickedness.
So when we read the whole world we need
to understand it means overwhelmingly
but there will be a few who will resist.
So when we read uh revelation 13:15 and
he had power to give life to the image
of the beast that the image of the beast
should both speak and cause that as many
as would not worship the image of the
beast should be killed. How do we
worship? We obey. The fundamental
principle of worship is obedience.
Recognize authority. I worship you
because I recognize you have a power
above me. The fundamental principle of
worship is obedience. And it must be
obedience to what? You don't obey a
person unless the person tells you to do
something. You just don't obey a person.
You obey what the person says. And so
this power will clearly pass a law that
people will have to choose to obey or
not obey. And those who don't will face
a death penalty. This is where the
crisis comes in. You see the final
crisis. Do I choose to obey God and
possibly die or do I choose to obey a
man-made law and save my skin
temporarily?
Temporarily because God will have the
final say. And so those who obey the the
the mark of the beast or the commandment
of the beast will have a mark. The mark
is not necessarily a tattoo. It is a a a
an acceptance
of a law that is contrary to God. And
that acceptance will be seen in the way
the person lives and the the way the
person worship. Those who are faithful
to God will also have a mark. We don't
use the word mark. We like to use the
word seal but it's the same thing. Those
who worship God will also have their own
mark or their own seal which will show
the world that they are following a
different authority and that authority
is God. And so the crisis is who has
authority to tell me what to do? Who is
very simple? Who has authority to tell
me what to do with regard to my
conscience and my worship? This is the
crisis that is coming upon this world
and it's not far away. I'm not a dates
setting person by any stretch of the
most elastic imagination. But
considering the way the country is
going, we can estimate that it's not far
away. Jesus said, "When you see these
things happen, know that the end is
near." So if he tells you the end is
near, then you're estimating without
setting a specific date. This is a
crisis that is coming upon this world in
a global way.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. You know, Papa Ski, I
like how you drew from Revelation 12,
>> which also spoke about a crisis, the
initial crisis, the war in heaven.
>> That's right. You know, and as you
rightly brought out, it's a it's about
the mind, a crisis of the conscience.
Who will we choose?
>> And as you were speaking the verse,
Matthew 10:28 came to mind. And fear not
them which kill the body,
>> but are not able to kill the soul, but
rather fear him which is able to destroy
both soul and body in hell.
>> That's right. That person is God.
Because God is a source of life, but God
is also destroyer of those who willfully
and implacably disobey him. He has to
execute the final punishment, which is
death. Because the wages of sin is
death. Uh also look at Elijah on Mount
Carmel. He told the people, "If God is
God, choose him. If Baal is Ba, choose
him. Choose one or the other." Again,
that's a crisis of conscience. Adam and
Eve in the garden, they had to choose.
God said, "You'll die if you eat." The
devil said you live if you eat. They had
a crisis of conscience. They had to
choose.
There has always been a crisis of
conscience. But this time it'll be
global and it will be the final time
that this will ever come upon human
beings because after that the end comes.
>> Amen. Amen.
Our second Yes.
>> Oh, no. No. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Our second question is how should we
prepare for this crisis?
>> Simple. Let me answer that part first.
>> Yes. Do we prepare for that crisis?
You know, God gives us good things and
we misuse them.
God gave the Israelites the sacrificial
system and the sacrificial system
literally replaced Jesus. They no longer
connected the sacrifices with the one to
whom the sacrifices pointed. And it
became so bad that in Isaiah chapter
one, God complained, "Stop bringing
these things to me. I don't want them."
They did not understand what he wanted
was the heart of the person given to the
redeemer who was to come. Now God has
given us prophecy. And in the same sense
that the Israelites misunderstood or put
too much emphasis on the sacrifices, we
sometimes are so fixed and fix fixated
on what's coming down the road. We don't
pay enough attention on how we live
right now. And that's the the problem
I'm referring to.
We yes we must study prophecy. We are a
people of prophecy. Prophecy guides us
and tells us how to uh interpret the
things that are happening and the things
that will happen. But we cannot forget
you and I can die at a moment's notice
before the crisis hits, before the
Sunday law hits, before the time of
trouble comes. You can die 5 minutes
from now. If that's the case, how are
you living now? Every day of life is a
crisis of conscience. choosing to obey
God or choosing to obey any other power
apart from God which ultimately of
course is Satan. And so when the
question is put how do I prepare for the
final crisis? I prepare for the final
crisis by living as obediently and
faithfully to God as I can right now.
The Bible tells us in Luke 16:10, "He
that is faithful in that which is least
is faithful also in much." If I don't
honor God's law now, if I don't return a
faithful tithe now, if I don't do what
God requires now, what makes me think I
can make it through the final crisis?
And so, the best preparation for the
final crisis is to be microscopically
committed to God. Now, what is he
telling you to do? You're not doing. If
you're not doing this little thing,
surely you can't do a big thing. And so
to answer the question, the first part,
preparation for the final crisis, the
the the the main thing is obedience to
God today. So if I die today, I am safe
with the Lord. It also includes the
study of God's word. Yes. Studying the
prophecies, yes, but not living in the
future. You study the prophecies, but
don't live in the future. You study the
prophecies which talk about future
events, but you live now. What's the
second part of the question, my
daughter?
>> The second part is what does watching
mean?
>> All right,
>> this is alluding from Matthew 242,
Matthew 25:13, Luke 12:37.
>> Okay, watching is not difficult to
define. Listen to what Peter tells us.
Be sober. Be vigilant because your
adversary the devil as a roaring lion
walketh about seeking whom he may
devour. It is impossible to watch
without the knowledge of the word of God
because it is through the lens of the
scriptures we can interpret what's
happening today and what consider what
may happen tomorrow. And so to watch is
to be aware to be conscious to have your
iter
maximally extended so that you can
understand what is going on around you.
You are on uh what's that in the
military you are on whatever guard duty
I guard. cannot sleep.
>> And so to watch is to be aware and that
awareness is based and rooted in a
knowledge of God's word and obedience to
that word. So watching is merely uh
seeing things through the eye of God and
the eye of God is the biblical
perspective.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. Our third question now
>> is where do we stand in the prophetic
stream of time?
>> How does this relate to Christ's work
for us?
>> We know based on Bible prophecy and the
sanctuary system that Christ is right
now concentrating his ministry in the
most holy place of the sanctuary. And
his work is an intercessory work on
behalf of those who have professed a
relationship with him who have sent up
their sins to him that he may cover
their sins with his blood or with his
life. That's the work that Christ is
doing. When that work is finished, he
comes back. Now read the question again.
I missed a part of it.
The first part of the question
>> is where do we stand in the prophetic
stream of
>> where do we stand in that's the one
that's the part we are we we we don't
have the precise date all we know is
that we see the attacks on the
constitution of the United States that's
going on right now we see the
undermining of what is considered the
the foundation stone of this nation we
know Eli tells us that will happen and
so it is happening before our very eyes.
Yes, we have no specific date, but we
can read the times, you know, we can
tell when rain is coming, when this is
happening. And Jesus makes that point to
the Pharisees. We ought to be able to
know, listen, we are at the very
doorstep of these final events spoken of
in the scripture and elucidated in the
writings of Ellen White. So, we're not
far from this law
being passed requiring the observance of
a man-made holy day. We'll put holy in
quotation marks. requiring the
observance of a so-called holy day by
man and that day is Sunday in opposition
to God's day which he established that
day is the seventh day of the week
called Saturday and so we're close to
that we're close to that when we look at
all the natural catastrophes and the
Bible talks about catastrophes as a sign
of the end time yes catastrophes have
occurred have occurred all through
history but not with the concentration
and the degree of violence we find um
what do you call those meteorologists
have told us that the natural disasters,
hurricanes, floods, whatever, are more
severe than they've ever been in all of
human history. And so, this is another
indication that we're close to this
climatic event, which is passing of a
law, which tells people, choose one way
or the other. You choose man-made law,
you live. You choose God's way, you die.
We are close to that.
And that should really cause us to sit
up and examine how we live. You know,
Peter tells us in second Peter chapter
3, I believe it's verse 11. Seeing
therefore that all these things shall be
uh come to pass or be dissolved. What
manner of persons ought you to be in all
holy conversation and godliness? If you
know these things are happening, that
was way in the time of Peter 2,000 years
ago. How much more intense is it now
that when we see these things happening,
we should take a look at our lives. How
am I living today? And so there should
be changes in lifestyle, changes in
priorities,
changes in family decisions, changes in
career decisions, changes that suggest
this person is aware we have not got
much less. We haven't got a lot of time
left on this earth because we know the
final events would be few and rapid.
Rapid
>> rapid. You know papa ski then I have our
last question but I think it fits more
in this thread. All right.
>> So it it is what is the cosmic week
>> and how does it amplify the times we are
living in?
>> Now that's a
what how should I describe that concept
of the cosmic week.
The Bible has
the week which God instituted at
creation. Six days of work, one day of
rest. The cosmic week refers to the
belief that the seven days of creation,
six of creation, one of rest, prefigure
a larger uh cosmic week, a larger week,
which is called the cosmic week. Meaning
between Adam and Christ are 4,000 years
between Christ and the second coming and
the third, the second coming. There are
2,000 years from Calvary to now. And
then the thousand years in heaven called
millennium spoken about six times in
revelation chapter 20. It is also based
on second Peter chapter 3:8. Let's read
that verse.
2 Peter 3:8.
>> But beloved,
>> Mhm.
>> be not ignorant of this one thing.
>> That one day is with the Lord as a
thousand years
>> and a thousand years as one day. Now,
that text is is the spinal text, if I
may use that expression, for the concept
of the 4,000 years between Adam and
Christ, two between Christ and now, and
one between Christ coming and uh the end
of everything a thousand years later.
Another text that may contribute is
Psalm 90 verse4. Let's go there. Psalm
90 verse4.
for a thousand years in thy sight
>> are but as yesterday when it is passed
>> and as a watch in the night.
>> Right now the Romans in the time of
Christ there were four watches I think
uh each one made up of three hours and
so Jesus came walking on the water in
the fourth watch of the night when it
was darkest. So a thousand years as a
watch in the night. It was slightly
different back in the Old Testament, but
referred to periods of hours that
represented the dark part of the day.
And so a thousand years in Nai are about
as yesterday when it is passed and as a
watch in the night. And so that also
contributes to believe that the Bible
teaches the earth has been around for
approximately 6,000 years. And when
Christ comes, he'll initiate the
millennium of a thousand years and that
will make it the seventh day or the
seventh uh cosmic cosmic day. Now, it
does not authorize people to set
specific dates.
I have no quarrel with someone who says,
you know, I believe Christ will come
within the next 10 years. I have no
problem with that because in in 18
before 1844, October 22, those who study
prophecy could say Christ cannot come
before October 22, 1844. And that would
have been correct. Are you following me?
Based on the study of the prophecies,
Daniel 8:14, someone could say
correctly, Christ will not come or
Christ will come sometime after 1844.
That is an estimation and that would be
correct. That I have no problem with
that. Looking at the times in which we
live, someone may say, you know, I
believe that Christ will be with us for
the next 15, 20 years. I have no problem
with that. When you tell me Christ is
coming September 31 or October 31, 2028,
then that's when I have a problem.
Because Jesus tells us no man knows the
day or the hour. He didn't say no man
knows the general time. No man knows the
day. Only a few days ago, the the rem
not the remnant, what's that word? The
um the the rapture was supposed to
happen September 23. Now, that we must
avoid at all costs. But I don't quarrel
with anyone who tells us there were
4,000 years between Adam and uh Christ,
2,000 between Christ and now. And
there'll be one more cosmic day called
the millennium. But we must also keep in
mind if you go back to second Peter 3:8.
But beloved, be not ignorant of this one
thing that one days with the Lord is a
thousand years and a thousand years as
one day. If we took that text to its
ultimate, then we can say the millennium
only lasts one day. Are you following
me? Because the text goes both ways. A
thousand years like a day, a day like a
thousand years. And so I am very careful
with this concept of 6,000 and uh one
millennium, another thousand. I don't
knock it. am just careful how I deal
with it myself because I don't know
anyone who knows exactly the day the
month when Adam was made or the earth
was created. I don't know how anyone
establishes that. And so the cosmic
week, yes, refers to 6,000 years of
human habitation on this earth. Christ
will come at the end of 6,000 and then
we'll be in heaven for 1,000. That's the
the the the seventh cosmic day. And
after that he comes back, remakes the
earth and heaven and we live forever and
ever on this earth. And um so that's my
view on the cosmic week.
Uh my good sister. But
conservative Bible scholars
refer to the earth as a a young earth.
A young earth. They dated it between 10
and 6,000 years. And ex a young earth
somewhere between 10 and 6,000 years.
And so there's some there's something
about this argument of the cosmic week,
but I just don't make it um the the the
monument or the pedestal on which I
stand. But I do not uh condemn those who
see some significance in it. No, I
don't.
>> Amen. I love this balanced approach.
It's important that we know that we are
not to date set. I saw that same video,
too. was a South African pastor saying
that
>> the rapture is going to take place
either September 23rd or 24th
>> and here we are September 27th
>> we're all still on well some folks I'm
sure passed away
>> so we are not to date set
>> but as you said we can tell that Jesus
Christ is coming very soon
>> we must be able to do that
>> we must have the power of discernment
you see the spirit of discernment must
exist in the church first uh Corinthians
12 uh verse uh 9 I I think an 8 uh 9 or
10. There must be a spirit of
discernment to see the times in which we
live to to notice this person's a false
prophet. He seems genuine or she but
really is false. The church must
possess. And so we must be able to
discern the times in which we live. We
must be able to do that. We cannot
discern a specific date. We must discern
the general nature of the times in which
we live. We know without knowing what
day of the week it is. If someone drops
me in Michigan after I come out of a
coma and I see snow, I know it is
winter. Are you following me? I may not
know it's November 3rd 3rd or December
18, but I know it is winter. I'm
discerning the time. If I see leaves
falling, I know it's the fall or in
other places of the world it's autumn.
And so we we discern the time. If I see
the leaves coming back, I know it is
spring. We must discern the times. And
so um yeah, the cosmic week there's no
nothing illegitimate or discerning the
times in which we live. But we must be
careful not to be specific. All through
history since Christ came to this earth,
people have been setting dates for the
return of Jesus Christ, none has ever
worked out. Not one. They have all
fallen flat. Yet people persist in
setting dates. And I don't know why
I said none.
But I believe we're close. And I want to
live that way as if we're close. To live
as if we're far would cause me to be
spiritually relaxed, which is precisely
what the devil wants. You have time.
Take it easy. No, you don't have time.
If you're mortal and you're not yet
sealed, you don't have time because you
can die right now. And so, we must live
as if the crisis is already upon us. And
in an individual sense it is because
every day we choose between Christ and
Satan by a life of obedience or
disobedience.
>> Did we actually cover all the questions?
>> We did not. We did not. We have a couple
more.
>> Okay.
>> I just jumped to the last one because
you were quoting second Peter and I said
>> this this would make more sense further
up.
>> Okay. Our next question is how does the
day of atonement
inform how we should prepare in these
times?
>> This is okay
>> in mind Leviticus 23 27.
>> All right. The day of atonement
an entire chapters devoted to it.
Leviticus 16. Of course we have details
in Leviticus 23 where all seven feasts
are listed. There were four major things
that were required of the Israelites on
that day. They were to uh assemble
around the tabernacle.
No work, afflict their souls, and I
believe put all sin and fast. Those four
things, no work. The day was to be
regarded as a Sabbath.
Come together in worship, convocation,
sins confessed,
fasting.
The day of atonement type, uh the
antitype began October 22, 1844.
Which means our lifestyle therefore
should be characterized by these four
things. Not that we don't work but work
does not become our priority. The thing
that consumes us and so that service to
God is damaged and is compromised.
We should be stressing convocation
coming together. I don't care what co
did to uh the church with all these
online services. We should get back to
coming together. Convocation was one of
the requirements of the people on the
day of atonement. Afflicting your soul.
Am I right with God? Psalm 139:23.
Search me God and know my heart. Try me
and know my thoughts. That should be our
thinking. Am I right with God? And of
course a fasting we are controlling all
we can. This base passion that led to
the fall of Adam and this base passion
that Jesus Christ conquered. When I say
based, not necessarily sinful. Appetite
isn't sinful, but appetite has no
decision-making apparatus in it.
Appetite has no conscience. Appetite
must be controlled by this. And so, we
use this to control appetite and other
urges which are perfectly natural and
normal, but need to be brought under the
control of an enlightened conscience,
the higher powers as Ellaw White refers
to them. So, these four things should
characterize our lives.
Work should not be our priority in the
sense that it dominates the life to the
damage of our spiritual lives. And this
happens to many of us. Our priority is
work. Work. Work. God invented work.
Don't get me wrong. He was the first
person to work in the Bible. Also the
first person to rest. But we should not
be consumed by work. So that as I said
it damages spirituality. Two, we should
find reasons to come together to worship
and pray and study the word of God.
Three, we should search ourselves. Am I
right with God? And four, fasting from
time to time. These are the four things
that should distinguish us. Not
necessarily publicly, but we know within
that that's how we think, that's how we
live. These are our priorities.
And so the day of atonement
should inform us and instruct us how to
live our lives so that we look like
people who are preparing to leave this
earth. When the Israelites were
preparing to leave Egypt in Exodus
chapter 12, God gave them the feast
called the uh the Passover, they would
eat it standing up. You got to move. You
see, you you eat it standing up. Your
staff in your hand, your shoes on your
feet. One staff in your staff in one
hand, you're eating with the other hand.
It's like uh Gideon testing the men,
lapping up water with one hand, a sword
in another. You can see these men are
ready for anything. We ought to live
like that. Not in panic mode, but in
alert mode, in watching mode, as we said
earlier, in vigilant mode, in sober
mode. That's the life we need today.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. I'm I'm going to ask
another question, bringing it up since
you're mentioning watching. What does
the parable of the five wise
>> and five foolish virgins teach us about
preparing for the final crisis?
>> Well, there's some things we should have
before the crisis hits. You know, I've
heard people say, "Well, just before
Christ comes, I'll repent." Well, that
that's a that's one of the most I hate
to use, let's say, unwise statements
I've ever heard in my entire life. The
five all 10 were virgins. You know,
everyone in church is nice. Okay, let's
assume that all 10 were virgins, five
were lost, five were saved. The five
were saved had extra oil which served
them when the cry came out, "Go ye forth
to meet the bridegroom." The other five
did not have and they could not get it
from the five friends. The shops were
closed. They couldn't buy it. We have to
be ready now with the spirit of God.
You know, we're we're because we're
people of prophecy, we know the the
spirit will be poured out in a very
large measure. We call it the latter
rain. Some people are living waiting for
the latter rain. But God has all already
given us the early rain. Are we using
the early rain? Are we living up to the
maximum the early rain will allow us to
live up to? Because only those who live
by the early rain will receive the
latter rain. And so, are we living to
the fullest by the power of the early
rain, which is what prepares us to
receive the letter rain
having Oh, there we go. I was having
trouble unmuting.
>> Oh,
>> there we go.
>> All right. Yes. Amen. Amen. Amen. You
know, another interesting thing about
the five wise and five foolish virgins,
you know, all of them slept.
>> All slept. Yes.
>> But like you said,
>> the wise were able to sleep knowing that
they had prepared before.
>> Whereas the foolish slept carelessly.
>> Yes.
>> Not preparing
>> for the bridegroom.
>> So, we've got to have things ready
first.
>> Because in such an hour as you know not,
the Son of Man cometh.
>> Yes.
>> So, we have to be ready.
Yes.
>> Mhm.
>> So, this is our final question, Papski.
>> Okay.
>> What is the relationship between the
final crisis
>> and the sealing of God's people?
>> Okay. Very good question and that's that
can take hours and hours, but we can
condense it a few minutes. The sealing
of God people is very opposite of the
beast putting a mark on people. As we
read Revelation 13 uh 13-15,
we meet God's seal in Revelation,
Revelation 7, uh where they're sealed
before, you know, the final crisis
breaks upon the world. The seal of God
of course is his his his law as as uh
condensed in the fourth commandment
which tells us remember the Sabbath day
to keep it holy. Uh we've traditionally
said that commandment contains God's
name. He's the creator. It contains his
territory of authority, the whole world,
his title, his lord, creator and the
whole universe is his area of
sovereignty. And that's his seal. It is
not a a mark place right here. It is a
lifestyle that makes it very clear who
runs your life and that life is God. You
know the word Christian was first used
by unbelievers. You understand when they
observe the children of God that their
lives revolved around this man called
Christ. They called them Christians.
So Christian is not a word that was
brought up by Christians. The
unbelievers observing their commitment
to this man called Christ called them
Christians. That was a mark in a certain
sense. So in the in the end time, the
the seal of God or the mark, it's also a
mark will be our commitment to God even
if it means death.
Eve because we will take that step
knowing there's a death penalty
mentioned Revelation 13:15-17.
And so the ceiling and the crisis, the
crisis, a crisis of conscience. Those of
us who truly love God and will obey God
rather than man. Acts 5:29, we will
choose to obey God's law, which is what
Adam should have done.
Because of that, we will be empowered by
the spirit of God, and our lives will
reflect that we are different from those
who choose a man-made law. We're not
setting out to show people up. We're
just setting out to be faithful to God
regardless of the cost. So when the the
image was made by Nebuchadnezzar in
Daniel 3, it was obvious that the three
who were committed to another god. They
were not bowing. You said, everyone else
was bowing. These three were not. And so
the calaldanss came to Nebuchadnezzar
and said there three men who were not
bowing. How did they know? They must
have been standing upright.
Something about their behavior suggests
they are different people.
When the laws pass, how will the
authorities know who is observing that
law, who isn't? Well, on the seventh day
Sabbath, we'll be going to worship our
God. Not on Sunday. And so, there will
be an outward behavior. Yes. That will
give evidence of the fact that this
person is obeying the God of heaven and
earth, not the laws that come from
man-made governmental halls of
authority. And so, the ceiling is God
putting his mark, not a visible mark. As
Ellen White said, it is a settling into
the truth so that nothing moves you, not
even the threat of death. Let me give an
example of that. Go to Acts chapter 20.
We look at the life of Paul.
This is what we need in these last days.
This is what has always been needed
really. Service to God even at the loss
of life. Because service to God must
require sacrifice. And a person not
willing to sacrifice life is not really
sacrificing.
M
>> Acts chapter 20. Let's read verse 22 and
23.
>> Yes.
>> Mhm.
>> I just pray. Father, thank you for your
word. Continue to speak through your
Holy Spirit in Jesus's name. Amen.
>> Amen. And now,
>> behold, I go bound in the spirit unto
Jerusalem,
>> not knowing the things that shall befall
me there.
>> Mhm.
>> Save that the Holy Ghost witness in
every city, saying that bonds and
afflictions abide me.
>> Now, there's something Paul knew,
something he didn't know. He was not
sure exactly what would happen to him.
He just knew he was heading for trouble.
Now, we don't have the microscopic
details about what exactly will happen
to us. We just have broad strokes. Paul
did not know all the details. He just
knew he was heading for trouble. But
here's what he knew 100% certainty. Keep
reading.
>> But
>> Mhm.
>> none of these things move me.
>> I am not threatened. I am not
threatened. Go on.
>> Neither count I my life dear unto
myself. Ah, Paul valued his ministry
above his life. We'll finish the verse.
>> So that I might finish my course with
joy
>> and the ministry which I have received
of the Lord Jesus
>> to testify the gospel of the grace of
God.
>> Here's what we have. Here is Paul's
life. Here is his ministry. He is ready
to sacrifice his life to carry on his
ministry or for the sake of the
ministry. This is what we need. You
cannot intimidate a person like that.
Here is a burning fiery furnace. Here
are the three Hebrew boys. They can just
kneel and then say sorry later. No, they
will not embarrass God. They were
willing to accept the fiery furnace. You
cannot overthrow a person like that.
Here's Daniel. Here are lions that were
deliberately kept hungry. You
understand? So they will devour anyone
thrown into that den. Daniel said, "I'll
pray to my God and deal with the lions."
This is what we need. There are many
people listening to me now who they see
the correctness of the seventh day
Sabbath. But they they will not
sacrifice job. They will not sacrifice
relationship. Will not sacrifice the
acceptance of friends and family. They
will not sacrifice that to obey God.
This is what we're dealing with. We've
always dealt with that from Genesis to
Revelation. Who deserves your life?
Are you willing to die for this person
called Jesus Christ? The crisis is
simply I am willing to die
in order to obey God. I will serve God
at the cost of my life. And there's
nothing symbolic about that statement.
The ultimate person who did that was
Jesus Christ on the cross. Nevertheless,
not my will but thine be done. I will
die. That's what you want from me. We
must say, Father, I will die in defense
of your law, which is defense of you.
Here is my life. Take it. I will not
disobey you. Case closed.
But most people listening to me or even
those not listening
when life is threatened they will leave
God. Are you listening to me? When the
devil knew that that's why he told God
when he tried to he took all of Job's
possessions. Job he went back to heaven
and God said see he's still faithful to
me. The devil said skin for skin all
that a man hath will he give for his
life. Let me touch him. He leave you.
But God said, "No, don't touch his line,
but touch him physically." Satan said,
"All that a man hath will he give for
his life?"
>> God has to test us. Who really is on my
side? All Christians say, "I love God. I
love Jesus." And I say it myself all the
time.
God said, "Show me how much you love me.
Lay down your life." And we say, "Wait a
minute now, Father. Don't go to
extremes. We're not extremists. We're
not fanatics." God said, "Show me how
much you love me. are you willing to die
for me as my son died for you? And until
a man or I don't mean to preach, but
until a man or a woman or a boy or girl
comes to the point where fidelity to God
is more valuable to them than their own
lives, that person is a prey of Satan.
Satan's greatest weapon is to threaten
life. When you threaten my job, you
threaten my life because I can't eat. I
can't have a house. I can't wear
clothes. And the job means everything.
It means survival.
God said, "Sacrifice survival for me."
Mhm. Die for me if necessary.
That's the highest proof.
Go to John chapter uh 15. Let me show
you something.
Read 12 and 13.
This is my commandment
>> that ye love one another as I have loved
you.
>> Greater love hath no man than this
>> than that a man lay down his life for
his friends.
>> All right. The greatest expression of
love is the sacrifice of life for
someone else. The Bible calls Abraham a
friend of God. So Abraham was God's
friend. God was Abraham's friend. The
Bible says the greatest proof of love is
to lay down your life for your friend.
>> Christ is savior, creator, lord, but
he's also a friend. Are you willing to
die for your friend?
Greater love hath no man than this that
a man lay down his life for his friends.
Then the verse, the next verse tells us,
"Ye friends, if you do whatsoever I
command you," not the pope, not
Constantine, "if you do what I command
you." And it was Jesus Christ on Sinai
who said, "Remember the Sabbath day to
keep it holy."
The seal is a mind 100% committed to God
with no not one atom of turning back.
>> Amen. Amen.
I'm wondering like should I add a verse?
But I feel like that just
>> Please go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Please.
>> First John 3:16 came to mind. Hereby we
perceive the love of God. Yes. because
he laid down his life for us
>> and we ought to lay down our lives for
the brethren.
>> That's a good point. I'm glad you raised
that. Not only should we be willing to
die for God, we must be willing to die
for one another.
>> Mhm.
>> Wow.
>> This is no joke. We must be willing to
die for one another. One another means
members of the household of faith.
Yes.
>> Amen. Now brothers and sisters, this
does not mean going committing suicide.
We do not
>> condone that. The idea here is if it
comes between honoring God and
disobeying God.
>> That's right.
>> We'd rather
>> choose to die than dishonor God.
>> That's right. Death before this.
Simplest.
>> That's right.
>> That's right. That's right.
Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Questions.
>> Oh, well, the last part of it is how can
we have assurance of salvation during
the final crisis? where to have the
assurance now. You see, but again, we
don't wait for the final crisis. It's
very simple. Do you have the assurance
now? What's today, the 20th? 27th of
>> 27th.
>> September.
>> September 27th. Do you have the
assurance of salvation? Now, I'm not
saying you run around saying, "I'm holy.
I'm righteous. I'm good." You know, I am
the first cousin of Jesus Christ. I'm
not saying that. Do you have the
assurance that Jesus is able to save
you? Not you can save yourself. You know
when the the the the uh the father
brought this epileptic boy and the
disciples couldn't heal him. Mark
chapter 9, the father said in verse 22,
"If thou can't do anything, have
compassion on us and help us." In uh
Matthew chapter 8, Christ came off the
mountain after the sermon on the mount.
A leper came to him and he said, "If
thou wilt, thou canst make me clean."
And so the leper said, "If you want to,
you can make me clean." The father said,
"If you're able," and Christ is both.
You see, Christ, he's able and he's
willing. And so we uh
we my sister, we must have that
assurance now that Christ is able.
Actually, Ellen White said the faith of
Jesus Christ as mentioned in Revelation
14:12 is total faith in Christ's ability
to save you fully. Absolutely.
He can do that. Do you believe that?
>> Can he deliver you from lesbianism, from
homosexuality, from pornography, from
self- abuse? Can he deliver you? You
must. Yes.
Your assurance is in that man who is
also God who created the entire
universe.
If he can create a universe, can he
sustain you? Of course, it is he that
sustains the angels.
No angel lives independent of God. The
only independent beings of Father, Son,
Holy Ghost. Every other living being is
dependent upon God. Can the creator
sustain you? The answer is yes. Have
that assurance now. And Calvary is the
foundation stone of that assurance. He
gave up his life. And there's no greater
cost, no greater demonstration of love
than sacrifice of life. Look to Calvary.
Therein lies your assurance. Accept that
unhesitatingly,
and you have no reason for doubt.
>> Amen. Amen. And amen. Now, Papaski,
we're gonna open up the floor for
>> questions as it pertains to the final
crisis. Okay.
>> So, those of you that are on Zoom, those
of you that are on YouTube or Facebook,
I'll pull up Facebook on my phone to see
if any questions
um are there.
>> If you are on Zoom and you have a
question, use the raise your hand
feature or the chat feature to pose your
question. Okay, I see Jabulo has asked
on what basis can you ask God to lay you
to rest before the crisis?
>> That's God's decision.
Uh asking God to take your life could be
an expression of selfishness.
You see, we we God needs us to show
faithfulness to him, faithfulness to him
in a variety of scenarios. For instance,
God may choose you to be very wealthy to
show the world how a wealthy person is
still humble and faithful to God. God
may choose me to be absolutely poor and
to demonstrate his power in my life in
my poverty. God may choose someone else.
I will allow you to have that sickness
so I can demonstrate my power in your
life in sickness. God chooses us in
various all kinds of human scenarios to
demonstrate that regardless of
circumstance, God should be reflected in
the life of the believer. When you ask
God to take your life, why
is this a selfish request? You see, why
God may want you alive
to suffer? God told Paul or he told
Ananas in Acts chapter nine, I will show
him how much he must suffer from my
name's sake. What great things he must
suffer for my name's sake. God told
Ananas, I will show Paul. Now, if I'm to
suffer, don't show me ahead of time,
please. But God said, "I will show
Paul." And Paul still went ahead and
served God. And so, we must be careful
about asking God to take us before this
happens or that happens. God may have a
plan to use us.
But if you're determined to pray that
prayer, you simply say, "Father, if it
is your will, then go ahead." And then
you leave it in his hands. But it could
be a selfish request asking God to take
you because you don't want to suffer.
Salvation requires suffering.
If you don't believe me, look at Calvary
and the Garden of Gethsemane.
Conquering self is the highest form of
suffering.
>> And you got to be well, you know, the
powerful, you know, we we have we don't
put ourselves in the hands of death,
>> you know. We live for God until living
for him means dishonoring him,
>> you know. So,
Amen.
>> All right. We thank brother Jabuno for
his question
>> and I pray I pronounce your name
correctly. Please,
>> I hope soon,
>> brother David. Okay, I see you've raised
your hand. I'll give you the the
opportunity to unmute and pose your
question.
>> Uh, hello, Mrs. Denanisha. Thank you for
this chance.
>> Mrs. Denanisha, just learned something.
Okay,
>> I'm married to the Lord. Praise the
Lord.
>> Thank you so much.
Uh thank you pastor also for this
chance. Uh
>> welcome my good brother. God bless you.
>> Yeah thanks. My name is David Gono. I'm
from Tanzania.
>> Oh God bless Tanzania.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thanks. Um I was just
wondering on the issue concerning the
time of trouble.
>> Mhm.
>> Since it also involves the time of
crisis.
>> Mhm. Um, Ellen G. White emphasizes both
the assurance of of forgiveness through
Christ
>> and necessity of overcoming sin.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. So, uh, especially before during
the time of trouble.
>> Mhm. Could you please help me to
understand how these two aspects work
together like uh if our sins are
actually forgiven during that time
because
>> uh it seems that
>> uh she stresses on the need that we
should
>> uh have a life of complete victory over
sin before the time of trouble. So
>> yeah.
>> So how should we balance the assurance
of forgiveness with the call to live
without sinning in that final crisis?
You can be sure I've confessed all my
sins of which I'm aware. You can be sure
of that.
>> The child of God is always wondering,
"Is there something I missed? Is there
something in me I've not confessed? Is
there something I'm not aware of?"
That's why David prayed in Psalm 139:23,
"Search me, oh God, and know my heart.
Try me and know my thoughts. And see if
there be any wicked way in me, any
wicked thing, lead me in the way
everlasting." And so in that time of
trouble actually the greatest suffering
will not be persecution. It will be the
mental crisis. Am I right? Have I done
something to God that I've not yet
confessed? That it does not change the
fact that you have the assurance. But
you you're wondering you're wondering
you're wondering because the closer you
come to God, the more you feel unworthy.
So when Isaiah saw God in Isaiah 6, he
said, "I'm undone."
The man called by God, he said, "I'm
undone." When Job saw God more clearly,
he said, "I am vile." Job chapter 40:4.
When Peter saw the power of Christ in
producing all the fish, he said, "I'm a
sinful man. Leave me." When Paul
recognized love of God, he said, "I'm
the less than, the least of all saint. I
am the chief of sinners." So that's the
reaction of righteous people as they
come close to God. It does not undermine
the assurance of their salvation. But
the the the holiness of God, the
righteousness of God as you approach and
approach this sense of being unworthy
overcomes you. But it does not remove
the assurance of your salvation. God has
that under control. So yet you see you
don't come to the place where you say,
"Ah, I'm fine. I'm fine. Now let me
smoke a vegetarian cigar." You never
come to that point. Are you following
me? You always wonder, "Am I am I? Am
I?" You're going through that. And that
would be the real crisis for the
believer in the time of trouble, not the
persecution of the government. Jesus
died from a broken heart, you see, not
so much from his the spears and whatever
else. His heart was broken.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> And so we have the assurance today. We
have that when Christ was on the cross
as a human being, he had his doubts in
the garden of Gethsemane. He had his
doubts. That's why he prayed three
times. Father, if thou be willing,
remove this cup. But that did not make
him any less the son of God. But
finally, when he died, he said, "Father,
into thy hand, I command my spirit." In
other words, he trusted the word of his
father. The father had told us in the
Bible, I think it's Matthew, not
Matthew, Psalm 16:10, he would not allow
his son to see corruption in the grave.
He would come back. And so, yes, we have
these questions, my brother David, but
our assurance remains steady. That's
what keeps us from losing our minds.
that somewhere we know I have I'm right
with God and God has God has me. He has
me. He's doing a work in me and he will
finish it.
But we're always uh we put no trust in
our own goodness or righteousness. We
put no trust and so we're wondering is
there something else? And that's a good
mindset to have by the way.
>> Amen. Amen. I know brother you aren't
able to unmute. I see we have another
question here on Zoom, but we have some
questions also on YouTube.
>> I want to at least ask one from here.
>> Um
just on
Okay, there are three questions here.
Two are on the topic. One is not is tang
not is tangentially related. Um I'll
start with the first one. How does one
know if they are of a reprobate mind?
And if they are, can it be reversed?
>> Well, of course. I mean, everyone born
in the flesh has a reprobate mind.
That's we're born leaning towards sin.
Of course, it can be reversed. That's
why Jesus Christ came to change the
orientation of the mind. You see, a
converted person has a a mind that is
reorientated or reoriented. I'm not sure
what the word is. So that the person now
leans in favor of God not in favor of
sin. Conversion is the reorienting a
renewing of the mind so that the person
leans towards God and away from sin. Not
the person is in tempted never falls but
the person's preference. There's a
natural urge for that which is right,
that which is holy, that which is
upright. You see, yes, the reprobate
mind can be conquered. That's why Jesus
Christ came. Nebuchadnezzar had a
reprobate mind. But he finally God
finally reached him. Paul who was Saul
had a reprobate mind. God reached him.
The reprobate mind is the possession of
the person who's not yet allowed Christ
to take control of the life.
So someone reprobate mind if that person
allows Christ, Christ can change that
mind. That is the power of Calvary.
>> Amen. Amen.
It is 4:00.
>> That's all right.
>> Okay. All right. So, I asked this
question since we spoke about sealing.
How would you know you've been sealed?
>> You don't know. You don't know. All you
know is right now I've given my life to
God 100%. That's why I keep stressing
right now. God doesn't send you a text
on Instagram to say you're sealed. All
you know is I prefer to die than to
dishonor God. That's all you'll know.
I've confessed my sins. I love God. I do
not want to hurt God at any price.
My life is for God. But you do not know
you're sealed.
All you know is I love God more than my
own life. That's what you know.
>> Amen.
All right. So, we'll I will zigzag.
We'll head back to Zoom.
>> Uh, this is from Joshua Gian. How do we
know exactly how God wants to use us?
>> How do you know exactly how God wants to
Well, let's pray again.
>> As we continue answering questions,
grant us simple wisdom. I pray in Jesus
name. Amen. Well, let's look at some
broad principles.
Sometime we get caught up on details not
realizing if we understand the
principles the details will fall into
place. Let's read the great gospel
commission.
Matthew 28 18 to20. Let's read that. How
do we know what God wants us to do? All
right. The great gospel commission.
And Jesus came and spake unto them
saying
>> all power is given unto me in heaven and
in earth.
>> Go ye therefore and teach all nations.
>> Right. Now, he said that to the
disciples. So, we know God wants us in
some form or fashion to proclaim the
gospel. Keep reading. Teach all nations.
>> Yes. Baptizing them in the name of the
Father
>> and of the Son and of the Holy Ghost.
>> Teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever I have commanded you.
>> And lo, I am with you always, even unto
the end of the world. So, we know that
whatever we do, we're called by God to
proclaim the gospel. Now, people
proclaim it different ways. Now, let's
read 1 Corinthians 10:31. We know it by
heart. Whether therefore ye eat or drink
or become a psychiatrist, do all to the
glory of God. Are you following me? So,
it covers every branch of legitimate
human endeavor. And I say legitimate, I
don't include selling dope or robbing
banks. Every branch of legitimate human
endeavor is covered by 1 Corinthians
10:31. And so you know that if I pursue
this professional line, will I glorify
God? And then we go to Isaiah 43. Let's
read verse 7.
Isaiah 43:7.
[Applause]
Even everyone that is called by my name,
>> I have created him for my glory.
>> Yes, we can stop right there. I have
created him for my glory, not his. This
is seen clearly in Genesis 1:26. And God
said, let us make man in our image after
our likeness. And now you put all of
that together, you realize whatever I
choose, it must be chosen in the light
of God's priority in my life. How will
this glorify God if I become a a
software engineer? How will it glorify
God if I get married? How will it
glorify God if I have another child? I
already have nine. How will it glorify
God if I move to Sri Lanka? How will we
must always ask the question, how will
this glorify God? And will this choice
grant me maximum ability and
opportunities to represent God?
And will it allow me to honor his
Sabbath? Which is the biggest question.
Will it allow me to honor his? Now, when
you keep this in mind,
you make choices with those
considerations in mind. And the spirit
of God will guide your choices. But you
know God wants you to be a witness. Go
to Acts chapter 1.
Let's add to that list of verses that
provide principles. Acts one, read verse
eight.
>> I knew I had a feeling you were going to
go.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Yes. But ye shall receive power
>> after that the Holy Ghost is come upon
you,
>> and ye shall be witnesses unto me both
in Jerusalem and in all Judea and in
Samaria, and unto the uttermost part of
the earth.
>> Witnesses for Christ. A witness tells
what he or she saw. Are you with me? A
witness doesn't give hearsay. This is
what I've seen. This is what I've heard.
As second Peter chapter 1, Peter says
we've heard him when we're with him in
the holy mount. And so all of these
things tell us when we make choices
about professions or work or
relationships. The first question is, is
this for the glory of this is how Jesus
lived. John 8:29. and he that have sent
me is with me. The Father hath not left
me alone, for I do always those things
that please him. We do the things that
please us. We choose jobs if they pay
well. We choose jobs if they bring a lot
of prestige and respect. We choose
whatever. We choose partners because
that's the thing to do. It's tribally
required. We have all kinds of
motivations for choices not connected to
the glory of God.
Jesus's concern always was, "Is this the
glory of God?" And so he could say in
his prayer, John 17:4, "I have glorified
you on the earth."
How he always did what pleased the
father
>> by the way, which means Jesus entire
life was a fast. He fasted from himself
because he said, "I do always the things
that please him." Then he fasted from
self. Can you imagine how painful that
life was to fast from self? And the
greatest urge is self-expression. He
fasted from self. And so the person who
asked the question and all those who may
benefit from it uh consider God first.
Will this glorify God? Will this permit
me to do the work as a witness, as a
disciple, as a child of God, always
thinking of God?
and God will show you what exactly what
he wants you to do. Then of course you
have natural talents and abilities. Do
you like to be with people? Well, don't
be an accountant somewhere in a
basement. Do you hate people? Well,
don't be whatever. You know you what are
my talents and gifts? What are my
aptitudes? You look at that and then you
make choices. Don't wait for the Holy
Ghost to tell you go and be a carpenter.
That will never happen. You have to use
your this as well. But when you use this
on the platform of the glory of God,
you'll make the right choices.
[Music]
>> I think you actually touched on this
question that someone asked, which is
how do you know the gift that God has
given you? And is it okay?
>> Ask your friends,
>> ask church members, what is I like? What
comes naturally to me? What would I do
even if I weren't paid? You know, you
you can you can tell if you search and
examine and you take time to reflect
while asking God, "Show me, show me,
show me, reveal, put an impression on my
mind." Everyone has gifts and talents.
Every single person. And as they use,
they can be multiplied. And so the Lord
will not leave you ignorant of what your
abilities are. He will not do that. I
knew from a little boy this big, I had
to be a preacher.
this big, a little smaller than that.
Whatever else you do, so God said you
have to preach. Whatever if you're a
pilot, preach. If you whatever preach,
preaching must be central to your life.
So that's it.
>> Amen.
>> If someone paid me a million dollars a
day to be a software engineer, God bless
all software engineers and take me from
preaching, my answer is no. As simple as
that. No.
Mm-m. That's not for me. If I were
offered the presence of United States
and Russia and China at the same time
running all three countries and take me
from preaching, my answer is no. Capital
N, capital O, exclamation mark,
underline, italicized, and bold print.
>> Mhm.
>> Amen.
>> Next question.
>> This is from my attorney Quashi. What
does it mean to truly have faith when we
face the final crisis?
>> Faith is simple.
>> Yeah. Faith is simply taking God at his
word.
Let's go to Psalm 27.
Faith is simple.
Psalm 27.
>> Mhm.
>> Let's read verse four.
>> One thing have I desired.
>> Verse five. Verse five, sorry.
>> For in the time of trouble, he shall
hide me in his.
>> In the secret of his tabernacle, he
shall hide me. Mhm. He shall set me up.
>> He shall set me up upon a rock
>> on sand. On a rock where I'm steady. I
won't move. Do you believe that? You
see, that's what God said. Do you
believe that? Faith is simply taking God
at his word. Of course, we got to
understand the word.
Remember the Bible begins with, "And God
said, let there be light." And there was
light. The word said, "Let there be
light." The light came. Can you trust
that word?
So faith is not complex. Faith
fundamentally is take God at his word.
But you've got to understand the word
before you take it. Which means you have
to study the Bible
>> intelligently.
And faith grows as your knowledge of
God's word grow and you obey. Romans
10:17, faith cometh by hearing, hearing
by the word of God. Without obedience,
faith cannot grow.
You'll shrink
>> without a knowledge of God's word. What
do you have faith in? To have faith in
God is to have faith in his word.
You cannot separate the two.
Next question.
>> This is from Aua. How can we bring the
flesh under the subjection of Christ,
especially with sins that easily beset
us? And she had another another
question.
>> Let's deal with that first. Let's do
that. Yes.
>> How can we bring the flesh under the
control of Christ? By the word of God.
Psalm 119:9,
"Wherewith all shall a young man cleanse
his ways by taking heed thereto
according to thy word." John 15:3, "Now
you clean through the word." Jesus
prayed to the father, "Sanctify them
through thy truth. Thy word is truth."
We must not, we cannot get away from the
word. Elite tells us in Christ object
lessons page 100 paragraph 1. If studied
and obeyed the word of God works in the
heart subduing every unholy attribute.
It controls uh ministry of healing page
458 paragraph 2. The reason why the
youth and even those of mau years are so
easily led into sin and temptation is
because they do not study the word of
God and meditate upon it as they should.
The secret is the word studied and
obeyed. Councils on Sabbath school work
page 43 paragraph 2. Study the word and
practice the word. It is your life.
>> It's not complex. The word,
the word was used to raise Lazarus.
The word is used to forgive sins. The
word was used to create the universe.
The word will be used to raise the
righteous dead.
The word
not complex at all.
Okay, finish the question now.
>> How can we use our careers to complete
Christ's mission?
>> How can we use It depends on what the
career is. Some careers are
illegitimate.
How can we use our careers to We have to
search. We have to use our minds.
Perhaps we're in the wrong line of
service. I don't know. But there is no
line of business, legitimate business
for which you cannot function as a child
of God. If that's the case, leave that
job. Any job that hampers your ability
to witness, leave it. Regardless of the
benefits, leave it.
One way to represent Christ on the job
is to do a good work. You know, it's not
enough to sing hymns and shout
hallelujah and go into Holy Ghost dance.
Are you providing excellent work on the
job? This is Christian behavior. Do you
respect your colleagues? This is
Christian behavior. Do you go the extra
mile? This is Christian behavior. Do you
get to work on time? This is Christian
behavior. How do you conduct yourself?
How do you speak to those who disagree
with you on the job? This is Christian
behavior. Are you cool when others are
in crisis? This is Christian behavior.
without quoting a text.
We must never forget most of our time is
spent in secular time. There's only one
holy day, but there's six secular days.
How can we live holy lives in secular
time? So on the job where we spend so
much time, Christ must be seen not only
in the length of our skirt and that's no
evidence of Christ or the shortness of
the skirt, that's no evidence of Christ.
It is in the attitude, the behavior, the
conduct. And so you read Genesis chapter
39:3
of Portifer and his master saw that the
Lord was with him. Portifer noticed
there was something different about this
young man. You can't believe Joseph went
around Portifer's house quoting from the
Old Testament which was written anyway
by that time. Clearly the way he lived
was a sermon in itself. And Portifer
realized the God I don't serve is with
this young boy. He observed him. We know
the most powerful sermon is the one not
preached but the one lived. We know
that. And so yes, whatever line of work
you do, you are there to you are hired
by God. Let's look at the principle of
work. I I hate to go off but this is
also answering the question. Go to
Ephesians 6 very quickly. Let's read
from verse 5.
>> Ephesians 6 verse 5.
>> Yes. From verse 5, we go 5 to 8.
Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> Servants, be obedient to them that are
your masters according to the flesh with
fear and trembling in singleness of your
heart as unto Christ.
>> Ah, now whatever line of work you're in,
if it's legitimate, not selling dope and
robbing banks, whatever line of work
you're in, work as if you working for
God.
And if you work that way, your earthly
employer will be greatly blessed as unto
Christ. Keep reading.
>> Not with eye service as men pleasers.
>> Yes.
>> But as servants of Christ.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Doing the will of God from the heart.
>> As if you're working for God.
>> God gave you the job. You're employed by
God. If you serve God to your maximum,
those who hired you at an earthly level
will be blessed and benefited as
Portifer was and Darius was when Daniel
was in charge.
And Nebuchadnezzar was when Daniel was
in charge and the three Hebrew boys were
in charge. So that's one way to
represent God. Keep reading.
knowing, excuse me,
>> with good will, doing service as to the
Lord and not to men.
>> Notice three times we met as unto
Christ, as to the Lord. As to the Lord.
You know, if you're dressing, dress as
if you're dressing for the glory of God.
Everything as to the Lord. You're in a
courtship. As to the Lord. It's a
fundamental principle. As to the Lord.
You're driving on the highway. I was in
a in um Augusta, Georgia conducting a
revival. I had a tremendous time. Ah,
the people were so sweet. Every night I
tell them, "Keep the speed limit on your
way home." And we'd all laugh. But you
have to drive as unto the Lord.
This is no joke. God must be the
dominant force in our lives. He must be
the motivation in all we do.
You You're exercising on the basketball
court, a pickup game, not keeping score.
score not necessary. God is not a god of
competition. Ask to the Lord. You foul,
put up your hands. You're guilty of sin.
You did it. As to the Lord. I'm not
trying to be funny, but as to the Lord
at the macroscopic level and the
microscopic level. As to the Lord.
All right, enough of that.
>> Next question.
>> All right, brother Bowen Steven.
>> Mhm.
He asks how would you know that the
dreams that you are having and the voice
voices that you are hearing which all
come to pass is from God and how do you
grow in that?
>> God used to communicate by dreams before
there was a Bible.
And so God told Miriam and uh and Aaron
and Moses in uh Numbers 12 verse 6. And
he said, "Hear now my words. If there be
a prophet among you, I the Lord will
make myself known unto him in a vision
and will speak unto him in a dream."
That was a customary method.
But when we got the Bible, old, new, now
we have Elawise council.
God's method of communication is not
chiefly dreams and visions at all. It is
the word of God. God will not create a
situation that allows you and me to
sidestep the word and just wait on
dreams and visions. Go to the word of
God. Listen to Jesus Christ in John
16:13. How be it, when he, the Spirit of
truth, is come, he will guide you into
all truth. For he shall not speak of
himself, but whatsoever he shall hear,
that shall he speak, and he will show
you things to come as you study the
word. I am not denying that on occasion
God may give a dream to a person here or
there, but dreams and visions are not
God's preferred method of cooperation
today. And you test it by the word of
God.
Is this dream requiring a conduct, a
choice that may disgrace God? This dream
or vision, whatever you think you've
seen or heard, or this voice, does it
conflict with the law of God to any
degree?
Does every doctrine, every theory, every
profession must be tested by the law of
God? Every preacher by the law of God.
And so, be careful with dreams and
visions. And uh it's a special gift God
gave to Daniel.
But God's method of communication today
is not dreams and visions. He has the
freedom to do it. But it is largely and
overwhelmingly his word. But we don't
want to study the word, some of us. And
so we want a shortcut. What does God
want me to do? Let him write it on the
sky. No, go study his word. Obey him.
And the spirit will guide your
conscience and your choice.
>> You eat, you know, you go to bed having
eaten a large meal and you you have all
kinds of dreams. You think they're from
God. No, they're not from God. They're
not from God.
>> Mercy.
>> Oh my.
>> Okay.
>> Next question.
>> Brother Kelly Edwards.
>> He said his question to you, pastor, is
>> Let me just quote him. Do I wait until
I'm qualified attending university?
>> It looks like I think someone is
unmuted. Just be sure to mute yourself.
>> Okay. Do I wait?
>> Do I wait until I'm qualified
>> attending universities or seminaries to
go out to to go out and preach or do I
just go because my heart yearns uh to
many folks see me as a pastor and
>> that's fine. I get Okay, we don't need
>> Now you don't have to wait.
>> Let me
>> Somebody needs to mute. We can hear a
lot of talking.
>> Please mute your mics.
Question. Unless that's coming from some
other planet, but someone needs to mute.
>> Yes.
>> Conversation going on.
>> Okay.
>> Now, the person said if he or he has the
urge urge upon him to do it, the urge is
not enough. If you're going to preach,
you must know what you have to say. You
have to study God's word. Don't wait
until you get to college, university, or
wherever. Study God's word. Learn it.
Live by it. So that there's power to
your presentation. You're talking about
something that's already working in your
life. But having a desire is not enough.
Because if you don't know the
scriptures, the doctrines, you may do
more damage than good. And so the desire
is good. Yes. Don't wait until you get
out of the seminary. Don't wait until
you're a professor somewhere. Right
where you are, what can I do to reflect
the love of Christ? Not necessary preach
to someone. What can I do to reflect? Do
I have friends who don't know Christ?
Can I meet with them to pray? Can I do
whatever? And as you grow in the
knowledge of God, then can I have a
Bible study in my home or in a friend's
home or maybe in the park somewhere, a
small group of us? There are
opportunities and ways to represent God
without waiting until you get a a
position as a pastor and you have a
pulpit. We can do something for God now.
But remember what I said, you must have
something to say,
and that's the Bible. study it, know it,
obey it, so you become an effective
communicator of God's grace and his
mercy and his love.
>> Amen. Amen. So, I'm I'm only going to
take about two more questions.
>> All right.
>> Uh,
okay.
>> Brother Japo is asking, should we work
in the cities or should we go straight
in the country in preparation for the
final crisis?
>> There are people in the city who need
the gospel.
We can live in the country, yes, but
work in the city. We cannot abandon the
cities. The cities have people who need
to hear about Jesus Christ. And if they
receive the message, they will come to
him. And so the cities are not to be
abandoned. They should not be the
primary location where we live because
of all the corruption, the distractions
in the city. But we cannot abandon this.
And by the way, let me also add there's
some people who need to stay in the
cities. Not every single person needs to
leave the city but God will direct you.
Some need to remain because God can
trust them to remain unsullied by the
city life remain and do God's work. But
most of us need to leave. But we can't
abandon the cities. We just relocate our
residents somewhere else but we come to
the city to do our work. Li tells them
we should have um some ministries in the
city where they help restaurants that
teach people how to to eat and cook and
that this if these things are in the
city we must come to the city to to to
to serve God. So yes the country God put
Adam in a garden not a city. The first
city was built by Cain who was the first
murderer. The first collection of cities
was built by Nimrod a descendant of
Cain. And so cities did not flow from
God. They flowed from the the sinful
line. But God has a city called
Jerusalem. And there's a new Jerusalem
in heaven. So we can't just abandon
cities. We live in a country, but we
come to the city to minister to those
for whom Christ shed his blood.
>> Amen.
>> People loves.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Now, attorney Kashi, I see you had your
hand raised. You may ask your question.
>> Hello, Papa Ski.
>> Yes, sir.
Um, I just had a question in regards to
uh teaching others about the final
crisis. Where should we where should we
begin? Should we begin with Daniel or
should we begin specifically on
Revelation?
>> Now, when you say teaching others, you
mean others Adventists or
non-adventists?
>> Non-adventists.
>> You begin by telling them about the love
of Christ and the dangers of sin because
they can collapse the very next day
after you teach them. I'm very serious.
We begin presenting the love of Christ
for this world. Love for a world that
did not love him, still doesn't love
him. Love for those, you know, you read
uh Romans chapter 5 verse verse 6, verse
8 and verse 10. While we were sinners,
while we were weak, while we were this,
Christ died for us. The love of Christ
for those who don't love him. Then we
teach the dangers of sin and that Christ
has made it possible to deliver us from
sin. That's where we begin before we
begin the final crisis. So they have the
foundation to understand ultimately the
final crisis is a battle between sin and
righteousness. Christ and Satan,
believers and non-believers. But begin
with the love of Christ, the sacrifice
of Christ. Why did he have to make the
sacrifice? Because there's something
called sin. What is it? Rebellion
against God's law.
>> Thank you. If you if you're talking to
Adventists, many of whom need to go back
to the fundamentals. When I think of
Adventists, I think of uh Hebrews
chapter 5:12. Let's go there. Someone go
to Hebrews 5, not five, four. Someone
read to Hebrews 4:12. Listen to what
Paul told the church. And it's a it's a
rebuke. Hebrews 4:12.
>> For the word of God is quick and
powerful
>> and sharper than any two-edged sword.
Mhm.
>> piercing even to the dividing a sunder
of soul and spirit and of the joints and
marrow. And it is a discerner of the
thoughts and intents of the heart.
>> Mhm. Chapter 5. Chapter 5 verse 12.
Chapter 512. What does that say?
>> Excuse me.
>> Mhm. 512.
That's a big cup.
Okay. Sorry.
5:12 of Hebrews.
>> So sorry.
>> Oh, it's okay. It's okay.
>> I've been sick.
>> And it really started affect me.
>> For when
>> for the time teachers,
>> ye ought to be teachers.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Ye have need that one. I'm sorry. Sorry,
I think somebody else going to have to
read.
>> It's okay. He have need. I want to teach
you again. Which be the first principles
of the oracles of God and are become
such as have need of milk are not strong
meat. Paul is saying you members of the
church, you ought to be teaching the
scriptures, but you need someone to
still teach you the fundamentals. So I'm
telling my good sister that uh even if
they're Adventist, you're teaching, you
may have to get back to the fundamentals
because many of us do not understand the
prophecies at all. A lot of SDS only
understand don't work on the Sabbath.
That's it. But there's much more to
being a 7day Adventist than that. We are
prophetic people based on Daniel 8:14.
Elaw White tells us the scripture which
above all other had been both the
foundation and the central pillar of the
Advent movement was the statement unto
2,300 days. Then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. Uh great controversy page 409
paragraph 1. And so you may need to take
Adventists back to the fundamentals
before taking them up to the time of the
the final crisis. But with non
Adventists, the love of God, the dangers
of sin, the righteousness of Christ
imputed to us when we trust him and
accept him fully as our savior. And then
you move from there gradually.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome, my dear. God bless you
in every possible way.
>> All right.
Okay.
So, I will take
there was one sister who had asked about
how do you claim
uh Bible promises?
>> How do you
uh let me see? Do we speak the word over
our life until we are delivered or
simply believe and walk in it?
That sounds a lot like a Pentecostal
language. You know, you just speak, it
happens. The only person who does that
is God. God speaks and it happen by his
word. We ask if God makes a principal
32:8, I will instruct thee and teach in
the way which thou shalt go. I will
guide you with mine eye. Now you need
guidance, direction, you go to that
verse. You say, father, that's what you
said. I will instruct thee and teach in
the way which thou shalt go. I will
guide you with mine eye. The eye of God
is his wisdom. The wisdom is the word.
And so that text requires us to study
God's word that he may guide us through
the word. You don't just say that and
speak it over your life and suddenly you
know everything. No, it does not bypass
at any time studying the word of God
because the word also says the entrance
of thy word giveth light. It giveth
understanding unto the simple. The Bible
also says, "Thy word is a lamp unto my
feet, a light unto my path." So when you
say to God, James 1:5, if any of you
lack wisdom, let him ask of God. He has
ask him, but don't ask and sit down and
speak the word over your life. And
suddenly you become as smart as Solomon
before he fell. No, you must go to the
word and study the word in that study
and obedience, then the wisdom is given
to you. And so when we talk about speak
the word over your life and it will
happen, no, that sounds very much as if
someone thinks he or she is God. You
claim, you trust your the word of God
that God does not lie. And you go to the
word of God. You study the word. You
study that promise. No promise of God
will allow you or me to bypass the study
of the word of God. And so we must be
careful about this. Speak the word over
your life and it will happen. And claim
this, it will happen. And no, no, no,
no, no. That's that's uh that's popular
among those prosperity preachers. Speak
it and it'll happen. and claim it, it'll
happen. M the promises of God are
connected to our relationship with him.
All the promises of God are based upon
obedience to him.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. I will have to make this the
final question, but I'm mainly asking it
because I think
>> may be beneficial.
>> Okay.
>> He says, "How do we let workers keep the
Sabbath? I live in a small African
village where having a watchman is
crucial to survive the night.
>> I wonder what I can do for Saturdays.
>> Why is why is a watchman crucial to
survive the night? And you're a child of
God. Now go to Exodus chapter 34. Let me
show you something. Exodus 34.
>> Yes.
>> Let's read verse 20. I think it's 20.
I'll read 23. 23
in the year
>> shall all your mench children appear
before the Lord God.
>> In other words, there were feasts. There
were seven feasts.
>> The first one Passover, the last one,
feast of tabernacles. Three of them
required all men to show up in Jerusalem
to celebrate the feast, which mean they
had to leave their homes. Now, here is
what God tells them. Read 23, then go to
24.
Then the air shall all your
>> men, children, appear before the Lord
God,
>> the God of Israel.
>> Mhm.
>> For I will cast out the nations before
thee.
>> Uh-huh. And enlarge thy borders. Neither
shall any man desire thy land, when thou
shalt go up to appear before the Lord
thy God thrice in the air. God is
saying, "If you obey me, I will take the
desire from people out of their hearts
to take your land. I will do that."
Because back then there weren't fences.
It was open land. They were
agriculturalists. And so there's the
risk of people coming and taking the
crop, taking the land. God said, "No one
will desire desire your land while
you're obeying me. No one will desire
your land." And so, while I sympathize
that we must be careful, we do what we
can to protect ourselves. But to say
that I cannot be protected unless I have
a watchman working on Sabbath, I can't
agree with that.
There are unseen angels that protect us
better than a watchman or a watch woman.
The key is, am I totally a child of God?
And God protects his children.
He really does. We do what we can and we
leave the rest to God. We don't have to
have someone break the Sabbath in order
to protect us because disobedience
removes the protection.
>> Amen. And amen.
>> You read Psalm uh 34:7. The angel of the
Lord encampeth round about them that
fear him and deliver them. Your
protection is God.
Obedience is what God requires of you.
Obey him. Leave the rest to him.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> God knows how to take care of the
enemies of his children.
But we can't have people disobey God's
law in order to benefit us. We can't do
that. By the way, I don't mean to cause
trouble, but if you live in a country
where it is customary to have a maid in
your house, and I've said this before on
this Q&A, that person should not work on
Sabbath.
But while you dressed and off to church
to worship God on the Sabbath day, you
have someone working. That person should
not be working on the Sabbath.
Oh no, thy son and thy daughter, thy
man's servant, and thy maid servant and
thy watchman.
Well, that's it, I think. My lovely
daughter, I think that's it.
>> Yes. Yes. There are more questions, but
if we don't put an end, they will just
keep coming in.
>> Take one more. One more.
>> One more.
>> All right. So, this question
>> he this is from brother Andrew. He's
asking on the final crisis about the
eastern question. Is Turkey is Turkey
the king of the north?
>> The position has generally been that the
the king of the north is the papacy,
not Turkey.
That's our traditional position. The
king of the north is the papacy, not
Turkey.
The king of the north is the direction
for which the enemy comes
and Turkeykey's not in the north. So the
papacy is regarded as the king of the
north.
Pagan Rome and paple Rome.
>> All right,
>> next question.
Uh, let me see here.
>> I said one more. I'm saying next
question. Okay.
>> Yeah. Sorry. No, there's No, it's all
right.
>> I know. I saw another one. Let me come
here. Uh,
>> okay. This I guess this is kind of
returning to what we spoke about earlier
in terms of dreams and visions.
>> The question is from Barbara. Is it
possible to hear or have dreams
>> uh and have visions? This is that that
you ask God if they are from him.
>> We can't tell God what to do. If God
chooses to give a vision, yes, he can do
that. What I'm saying is God's
predominant method of communication
today is not dreams. It is not visions.
So we must be very very careful with
these dreams and visions and seeking for
interpretation.
We must be very careful. But I cannot
say that God will never ever decide to
give a dream or a vision. I can't say
that. All I can say is the Bible is our
guide and God will speak through us
through his word overwhelmingly.
So don't go looking for dreams and
visions because the devil may see that
you get them.
>> Amen.
>> Pick one question that's not related to
crisis but you think can be a blessing.
One question not related to the final
crisis but which you think can be a
blessing in the answer.
>> How are we supposed to study the Bible?
>> There are many ways to study the Bible.
Elawite recommends one way. Study the
lives of Bible characters. Pick someone.
Let's say Joseph uh Genesis 39 and
onward. How he functioned in Egypt. Why
do you think God chose him to be the
savior of his people and also the
Egyptian nation? study the life of
Joseph or you may study the life of
Abraham from Genesis 12-2 or you may
study the life of Enoch there very
little about him but you read the little
verses about him and then you study what
kind of a man was Enoch or you study the
life of you know Peter or Paul or
whomever that's one way another way is
to study a theme in the Bible let's say
righteousness you start with a first the
word is first introduced
whether righteous or righteousness and
you trace that word through the
scriptures which of course will take
time seeing how it is used if there are
variations in the application of that
word or you may decide to uh
first of all Bible study should be very
personal in the sense you're studying to
discover God's will for you that's
number one reason not to win an argument
but what is God telling me in my
onetoone relationship with him a friend
of mine years ago gave me this method of
study. Ask a lot of questions. You take
a verse, what is it saying? What does it
say to me? What does it tell me about
the love of God? What does it tell me
about the love of God? How does it help
me understand another Bible verse? You
understand? How can I use it to
encourage somebody else? So, you ask
questions like that as you read. There's
another method where you ask who, what,
why, who is speaking,
what's the situation, you know, and why
or where. you know those basic question
who, what, why, where, which or
whatever. That's one way you can study
the Bible as well. And so when we read
in the beginning, God created the heaven
and the earth, Genesis 1:1, who, why,
you know, where, what, you try to answer
those questions. So there are variety of
ways to study the Bible, but you pick
the one that is of greatest blessing to
you.
By blessing I mean it increases your
knowledge, draws you closer to God in
the reverse order but they can't be
separated really but close to God
increases knowledge.
>> Amen.
>> Always remember the ultimate teacher is
the Holy Ghost. John 16:13.
>> Well, that's it.
>> Yes. Yes. We will pause right there. We
will pause right there. Mhm.
>> I saw someone had a question on the
special resurrection. We did a whole Q&A
on the resurrection and spoke about
that.
>> So, feel free to check that video out in
our playlist with Q's Q&A with Elder
Renie Sk.
>> Okay.
>> Well, Papa Ski, it was a pleasure once
again
>> to have you here as we delved into
preparation for the final crisis. Thank
you for giving of your time freely and
giving even extra time to answer to
answer the open form questions. May the
Lord bless you to
>> and your wife
to keep you both in his bosom.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> So my friends in South Africa, I'll be
there October 9th through 30. 9th, no,
9th through 25 in Cape Town at a church
called Riverside, I believe it is. So, I
look forward to that very much. Very
much. I don't usually advertise where
I'm going, uh, but it just occurred to
me just to say that I'll be in Cape Town
October 9 through 25,
Riverside, somewhere in Cape Town area.
Okay. So much for my advertisement.
>> Amen. May the Lord put his angels around
you to protect you.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Anyone that may try to harm or hurt
>> in
>> Jesus's name.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you, my dear. God bless you. All
those who listen, God bless you. And let
me encourage you. Study the word of God.
Live by it. Believe it. Obey it. It is
your life. It really is your life. In uh
evangelism, page 138, paragraph 4, Elite
writes, "To study the word of God is to
eat the leaves of the tree of life. It
is your life. Study it and obey it.
The highest expression of faith is
obedience
cuz faith without works is dead.
>> God bless you all.
>> God bless. God bless. Thank you so much,
Papa Sket. To all of you that joined
this evening, thank you for being here.
Your participation and interaction was
very felt. May the Lord continue to
bless us all as we seek him and seek his
truth and by his holy spirit put it into
practice. I look forward to seeing you
all by God's grace next month, the
fourth Sabbath of October.
We'll be doing something themed around,
of course, the Great Protestant
Reformation.
So stay tuned for that. And until next
time, thank you for your presence. As
you can hear, my voice is a bit
horsearo. In fact, I had to speak this
morning at church. I've been sick since
Tuesday, but God has preserved me so
that I am here. And I'm grateful that we
were able to have this discussion today.
And as Papaski has said before, I pray
this be not just an academic exercise,
but that we truly take time to reflect
and ruminate on the gems that we have
uncovered today and ask the Lord to fit
it into our hearts and lives. All right
then, brothers and sisters, thank you
again for your time. Thank you for your
participation. Take care and God bless.
Now, before we go, I'm going to leave
with you a meditative song by Dr.
Natasha Willis. And right after this
song is played, I will end the live.
[Music]
Years of time have come and gone
since I first heard
told
how Jesus
would come again someday.
If back then
it seemed so real,
[Music]
then I just can't tell but feel
how much closer
he's coming
is today.
[Music]
Signs
of the times
are everywhere.
[Music]
And there's a brand
new feeling
in the air.
[Music]
Keep your eyes
upon
the eastern sky.
Lift up your
redemption
draw.
Wars and strife on every side.
and violence
fills the land.
Still some people,
they doubt you'll ever
come again.
[Applause]
Oh, but know the word of God is surely
true.
He'll redeem his chosen few. So don't
lose hope
for soon Jesus Christ he will he will
desel.
Oh,
signs of the time
are everywhere.
[Music]
And there's a brand,
new feeling
in the air.
[Applause]
So keep your eyes
upon
the Eastern sky.
Lift up your hand
redemption
and tr.
Don't keep your eyes
upon
the Eastern sky.
Lift up your head.
Redemption
in drawing night.
Redemption draw.
[Music]
Father, thank you that our redemption
draws nigh. May we be prepared for your
final the final crisis. In Jesus's name
we pray. Amen. All right, brothers and
sisters, take care and God bless.